[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
mais à
allez
où
le violoncelle c'est pas mon métier
métier c'est de vendre des vélos
par contre le violoncelle c'est ma
passion
et c'est ce dont j'aimerais vous parler
aujourd'hui
alors avant de vous raconter c'est
pourquoi je suis là devant vous
j'aimerais vous poser une petite
question
en levant simplement l'amant la main
dites-moi qui d'entre vous jouent d'un
instrument de musique
parce que vos parents vous l'ont un peu
imposée
d'accord non je vous invite à garder la
main levée si vous le regrettez
peau visiblement il ya personne qui le
regrettent
remercié alors la prochaine fois vous
les verrez merci
et bien moi c'est comme vous
je dirais plus particulièrement ce sont
les femmes de ma famille qui m'ont
transmis l'amour de la musique à travers
le violoncelle
maintenant j'aimerais vous emmener
114 ans en arrière en 1908
c'est l'année de fabrication de ce
violent celle que vous avez devant les
yeux
[Musique]
sa première propriétaire c'était mon
arrière grand mère
une jeu long 6 très douée elle a joué
juste que ces 22 23 ans elle a gagné des
prix des concours
et puis un jour elle a épousé un homme
qui n'aimait pas la musique
à peu près en même temps la guerre est
arrivée
elle a donc rangé son violoncelle dans
south là on est dans son grenier
est la plus touchée pendant près de 50
ans
vous imaginez
mais vous vous dites bien que s'il est
là devant vous aujourd'hui c'est que
l'histoire ne s'est pas terminée là
dans les années 80 c'est ma maman qui
s'est mise au violoncelle
alors une année pour noël sa grand mère
est retournée dans son grenier a
dépoussiéré son violoncelle pour
l'offrir à ma mère qui en jouant dessus
a permis à a permis de redonner vie au
bois aux cordes à l'archet à tous qui
vieillissaient et qui dormait depuis
beaucoup trop longtemps dans ce grenier
alors pour que plus jamais cet
instrument ne soit abandonné aussi parce
que mon papa a craqué pour ma mère le
jour où il l'a vue jouer pour la
première fois
mes parents ont décidé qu'un de leurs
enfants qu'une leur fille
jouait du violoncelle
étant la première fille de la fratrie
j'ai pas eu le choix c'est tombé sur moi
alors comme ma mère avant moi et mes
petites filles après moi j'espère j'ai
un grand devoir envers cet instrument
c'est d'en prendre le plus grand soin de
toujours continuer à jouer et surtout de
lui trouver un successeur dans ma
descendance qui prendra le relais comme
moi je pourrais plus jouer
alors je raconterai cette histoire que
je viens de vous partager pour qui ils
ou elles comprennent l'importance de
toujours continuer à transmettre ce beau
cadeau qu'on a reçues cette passion de
la musique
cette tradition familiale c'est donc la
première raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui je joue du violoncelle
mais vous imaginez bien que ce serait
pas suffisant une petite tradition pour
motiver tout le travail et toute
l'implication que cet instrument demande
alors peut-être que vous vous posez la
question
moi en tout cas je me la suis posée
pourquoi aujourd'hui à 23 ans je joue
encore du violoncelle
pourquoi je m'y accroche pourquoi je me
bats pourquoi j'y passe tellement de
temps
alors que c'est même pas mon métier
j'ai jamais gagné un sou avec
et bien c'est tout ce que j'ai reçus au
delà de l'instrument c'est vrai c'est un
super du conseil il a un son incroyable
il ya quelque chose de plus fort de plus
grand
ce sont des valeurs de partage des
rencontres les émotions qui me permet de
vivre est ce que ce que je peux faire
ressentir au public aussi tout ça c'est
beaucoup plus fort et cet instrument
fait maintenant tellement profondément
partie de qui je suis aujourd'hui
je pense que si on enlevait il ne serait
pas grand chose
c'est peut-être surtout pour ça que je
continue à jouer
ce que j'adore avec cet instrument ce
qui me permet de rencontrer plein de
personnes ça forme un peu entre ig hante
le sont chaleureux et le fait qu'il soit
peut-être moins commun qu'une guitare ou
qu'un piano
l'amène à moi plein de personnes des
musiciens des mélomanes évidemment mais
aussi des personnes curieuses qui a
priori n'ont rien à voir avec le
violoncelle
et quelques semaines je prenais le train
qui était complètement bondé genre un
dimanche soir avec mon violoncelle et
donc j'étais assise avec mon violoncelle
là qu'ils rentraient complètement dans
les genoux de la face enfin de la femme
en face de moi parlons donc je m'excuse
évidemment et elle me répond contre
toute attente il n'y a pas de problème
c'est bien violoncelle oui
c'est le plus bel instrument de la terre
alors on s'est mise à parler de musique
de violence elle pas très longtemps mais
je crois que on se serait jamais parlé
si j'avais pas mon instrument serait
chacune rester sur nos téléphones quoi
s'est régulièrement je croise aussi des
enfants qui me regardent un peu comme ça
de travers maman c'est quoi ce qu'elle a
sur le dos la madame
moi quand j'entends ça je vais voir
l'enfant et je lui explique ce que j'ai
sur le dos je lui dis que c'est un
instrument merveilleux
et qu'il faudrait d'ailleurs qu'il en
fasse
mais il ya également entre des musiciens
quand ils se rencontrent quand il joue
qu ils créent ensemble
une relation unique qui n'est ni amical
ni amoureuse mais qui est extrêmement
forte
moi quand je joue avec d'autres que ce
soit en orchestre ou simplement en duo
je peux terminer des morceaux toute
tremblante d'une émotion indescriptible
inexplicable mais super agréable
et cette émotion cette sensation elle
est encore plus forte quand on improvise
l'improvisation c'est plusieurs
musiciens qui vont créer des mélodies
sur une moment à partir de leur
imagination leur émotion de ce qu'ils
ont vécu dans la journée chacun joue sa
mélodie et au bout d'un moment on sait
pas trop pourquoi ni comment mais les
mélodies se rejoignent et forment
ensemble une sorte d'harmonie de
synergie qui est exceptionnel
je sais pas s'il ya des musiciens ce
soir dans la salle qui ont l'habitude
improvisé si c'est le cas je suis sûr
que vous partagez ce sentiment avec moi
ce sont donc toutes ces rencontres
qui m'ont permis d'aller plus loin que
mes suites de bach
qui m'ont emmené là où je n'aurais
jamais cru mettre les pieds un jour
je me suis retrouvé au pérou dans une
jam à jouer avec des gens dont je ne
parlais même pas la langue je me suis
retrouvé dans des musiques de films et
aujourd'hui devant vous sur une scène de
tedx
m'aurait dit ça ya six mois j aurais
jamais cru je crois que là tout de suite
je crois même pas vraiment
maintenant j'aimerais vous inviter à
fermer les yeux
et essayer d'être attentif à ce que vous
allez ressentir physiquement
et au niveau de vos émotions et où jouer
quelques notes
à
le
[Musique]
oh
le violoncelle c'est un instrument aux
vibrations extrêmement forte en
particulier quand on joue dans les
graves
alors si vous pendant que j'ai joué vous
avez ressenti une petite vibration
petite émotion
mettez vous à ma place
moi qui ai cet instrument qui vibre si
fort tous contre moi
ça fait un bien fou
la violoncelliste lisa ends elle décrit
cette sensation en dix ans les
vibrations se transmettent qu'à mon
corps
irradie tout l'espace
je les ressens par le sternum par les
jambes le violoncelle ronronne d'elle un
énorme char
on a déjà tous eu un chat qui ronronne
sur les genoux et rien de plus apaisant
et bien moi pendant et surtout après
avoir joué je me sens souvent apaiser un
peu déconnecté du réel envolées les
skype
mais rassurez vous ces vibrations les
gars pas que pour nous violoncelliste
elles sont bénéfiques à tous ceux qui
tendront l'oreille
le violon le violoncelle à d'ailleurs
démontré des vrais effets thérapeutiques
permettant de réduire la douleur
soulager l'anxiété
clair aux perses et une violoncelliste
qui en a fait son métier
l'a quitté la scène pour rejoindre des
ehpad les établissements pour enfants
atteints d'autisme elle a écrit un très
beau livre qui s'appelle le pansement
schubert je vous invite à lire qui
commence par cette scène dans un ehpad à
paris
il ya une patiente qu'on essaye de
soigner qui se débat qui hurlent dans
tous les sens et claire passe à ce
moment là dans couloir rentrer dans sa
chambre s'arrête du joue un morceau de
schubert et instantanément
la patiente s'apaisent
son visage ses bras ce cannes où elle
arrête du relais les infirmières peuvent
la soigner
juste avant de quitter la salle il ya
une des infirmières qui dit à clair il
faudra revenir pour le pansement
schubert
alors je vous ai parlé de l'impact
physique que violence elle peut avoir
sur nous musicien sur vous qui écoutait
le violoncelle
et vous imaginez bien
que les émotions aussi nombreux en
prennent un coup
au plus je joue au plus je me rends
compte que la musique permet parfois
d'exprimer ce que les mots ne peuvent
pas dire permet de compléter là où les
mots sont insuffisants
et quelques mois je suis rentré chez moi
le soir après une journée et j'étais un
peu déprimé un peu triste
le blues du mois de novembre quoi
et je me suis mise à mon instrument et
anjouan je me suis rendu compte que la
musique exprime est exactement ce que je
ressentais au plus profond de moi et que
j'arrivais pas à expliquer
après ça je me suis senti mieux
la musique permet donc de mieux
comprendre accepter digérer certaine
émotion pour plus facilement les laisser
partir
c'est pas pour rien qu'on écoute de
musique triste quand on a un chagrin
d'amour
alors je vous ai parlé des vibrations
incroyable exceptionnelle de mon
instrument
qu'est ce que vous savez ce qui permet
toutes ces vibrations
c'est un petit bout de bois vous voyez
pas il se trouve juste là d'ailleurs
il permet de faire vibrer de faire
entrer en vibration toute la caisse de
résonance sans ce petit bout de bois
vous n'entendrez rien le son et resterez
là
est ce que vous savez comment on appelle
cette pièce
c'est l'âme du violoncelle
moi je crois que ce nom il n'a pas été
choisi au hasard
parce qu'il ya un parallèle assez
intéressant à faire avec l'être humain
chez nous l'âme
c'est ce qu'il ya de moins tangible de
moins visibles et pourtant c'est ce qui
fait que nous sommes c'est ce qui nous
fait vibrer
alors moi je crois que quand l'âme du
violence elle entra en vibration c'est
noam quelle douche
[Musique]
je
oui
[Musique]
je
où
alors s'il ya des vieux instruments qui
traînent dans les greniers de vos grands
parents font c'est jeter un oeil vous
tomberez peut-être sur un petit trésor
comme celui ci qui vous permettraient
permettrait à quelqu'un d'autre de
s'épanouir
de repousser ses limites de faire des
rencontres incroyables
et de faire vibrer le monde
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous